yes today we're talking about yu-gi-oh I
don't care I don't care we're doing this
for whatever reason I never saw this
anime as a kid I think I was too old but
I'm really glad I didn't because now I
get to watch it as an adult and
appreciate just how bad good it is for
ever reason I watched it okay I watched
it I watched a whole season but I want
to focus on episode one because if you
don't know anything about ukyo the whole
episode is like what is happening I love
it let's let's review the episode
[Music]
you know other animes have some
inspiring message we gotta be the number
one that kind of thing here it's just
like it's so bad hey Joey earth to Joey
hey are you in there it's your turn
oh isn't it cute so the anime starts off
with the main protagonist Yugi and Joey
for whatever reason Joey speaks in like
a thick New York accent hey Tristan Yugi
he's teaching me how to play duel
monsters drooling monsters duel monsters
you Nimrod
sheesh they've been at it for hours
Joey's starting to get the hang of the
game they've been at it for hours in
school the game is so addicting go buy
it now they've been at it for hours like
Yugi's like an expert
okay Yugi it's time to duel see each
card has an attack number that's such a
shitty card so apparently the mango this
is really good
but the anime wanted to focus more on
selling actual products so it's more
based on the card right first player to
eliminate their opponents Life Points
wins the duel pretty good move pretty
good move hai and place the card on the
fear way to give me huh
I know this is for kids but I can't get
over how dumb it is pretty good boo but
not that's a better card this is
literally what we used to do when we
didn't know it because we had too many
brain thoughts too many brain thoughts
my brain is overloading okay when I was
a kid hey I don't remember your name it
was some sort of foreign aid and I will
sound racist if I say it but this'll
hurt didn't know how to play poker but
you know who you are I bet you're
watching he was like oh I know there was
a Pokemon I'm like alright let's play it
let's play pokemon that he's like
alright so basically you just picked the
first card of your deck and you place it
down and that whoever has like the
strongest card wins the other person's
card and I'm like that sounds stupid and
he's like alright place a card and I'm
like alright it's some vulpix or some
sheep and he just pulls out a shard
right away he was like all right your
card is mine now I'm like No so that's
how duel links work they figured it out
because no one knew how to play the game
even though they're so simple
[Music]
thanks a lot thanks 9
thanks for beating me what the hell why
would you say that I wonder what the
Japanese version is thanks why would you
say sarcastically thanks if someone
beats you in a game
thanks um whoa you stink at this game
Joey yeah you did fine Joey I just have
better cards see damn wait to rub it in
you just had better card
owns a game shop and I get all my best
cards from him that's not fair
privileged Yugi and his stinky grandpa
he's basically the equivalent of my dad
works for nintendo my my grandpa has a
game shot roam game shop what are we
waiting for let's go okay maybe I can
even get my grandpa that's my hero super
rare call rice guy over guard rare card
could they have found the card that I've
been searching for how do they do this
voice acting on ironically rare card
could they have been the searching card
I can improve my rare card my god Kaiba
is my man
Gramps could you show my friends your
awesome super rare card rare card my
special card hmm
please please please that's a tough one
that's a tough choice should he show the
rare card is grandpa going to show the
SuperDuper rare card I mean you can't
just show a rare card to anyone that's
how you know this is not realistic cuz
anyone that has a rare card could not
stop himself from showing the rare card
it's like nobody hey have I showed you
my rare card how can I refuse you guys
are in for a treat I don't take this
card out too often but ready here it is
blue-eyes White Dragon he has a box that
you have a super rare car and you
haven't even put the laminating plastic
over it and you're running a game shop
grandpa you don't know what you're
talking no wise right track it's so rare
so powerful I never let it leave my
hands Oh hmm
this card is priceless there are only
four of them in all the world
speaking of priceless I'm ready to trade
for this card look I look at a
psychopath he's like Gollum in Lord of
the Rings with this card income sky but
of course he wants a card
doesn't he have a big fancy company to
run what's he doing down here I mean he
also goes to school doesn't have a big
fancy company to run
why is he in school not that it's any of
your business but I came to see the card
he wants the card Kaiba is like I'll
give me the card grandpa's like nah I
got this card from so special well
enough window-shopping is there anything
else I can help you with
whoa listen to me old man give me your
blue-eyes White Dragon card and I'll
trade you all of these damn damn I never
even seen these are these are these real
I can't tell you got the card from her
friends completely so she's not gonna
give it up no no I've heard enough of
your nonsense senile old fool these
cards are all about power and one way or
another is blue-eyes White Dragon card
will be mine
dude look how static this is that's
pretty awesome that's some vibes right
there look at that pinkish car tone from
the sky that's amazing and the maze art
you don't understand all right but it
gets it gets more confusing all right I
guess this is company five buddy there's
a little something I'd like you to pick
up for me at the game shop at the game
shop that one game shot good morning
my master Seto Kaiba challenges you to a
duel you will come with us no and if I
were to decline I'm afraid I must insist
young Kaiba doesn't understand but I'll
teach him a lesson about the heart of
the cards Kaiba basically kidnaps you
describe that for a doll amazing
look how Yugi's walking
how tall is Yugi he's like half the
length of everyone then why would the
cards change the Dame from the you never
even been in the shop before man I hope
he has some cool cards today their
writing doesn't make any sense and I
wide awake Eric hey hey grapes grandpa
oh maybe he went I did baby but why
would he leave the door unlocked
hello game shop ah Yugi perfect your
grandfather's here visiting but he's not
feeling well his granddad up this is
what in the show just gets so confusing
and I love it
[Music]
due to him
they played cards why is he dying why is
he on the floor what happened I want to
know I need to know what happened what
did he want you to teach that boy Kaiba
a lesson about the heart of the cards
but I lost and now I'm dying for no
reason so the whole concept is that
Kaiba believes in the power of the cards
but grand that is like there's hearts in
the cards yes actual hearts in the cards
you believe in the cards and you get
good cards basically if I'm like I
believe I draw a good card because I
believe in heart of card that's the
concept of Yugi I just explained it
how's the old man feeling how's he
feeling he's dying he's died hey you
sleaze what have you done to him
we had a duel that's all with each of us
putting up our most valuable card is the
prize and look at the prize I won no if
you want it why did he have to destroy
it can someone explain if he has three
or life to have four in a deck does he
know that just say he did not have to do
that yes the blue-eyes White Dragon is a
rare and powerful card and this one will
never be used against me you could have
just put it in your own deck ah my
blue-eyes White Dragon he's definitely
dying now how could you do such a thing
yogi but clearly it doesn't work your
garbage deck is not good enough gran
died I put my soul in these cards and I
taught you everything I know yogi
then take my teaching respect to eat it
I think it's a little too late for that
he destroyed your car that was the whole
point
each khyber respect for the heart of the
cards Yuki but grandpa you need help
I've got to get you to a doctor sounds
but grandpa you need help we could take
care of your grandpa while you take care
of creepy Kaiba teach that rich spoiled
brat would a real duels all about just
go and help your granddad what are you
doing
everyone put your hands together oh yeah
she gets this good idea to draw a smiley
face over everyone's hand it doesn't
even look like a smiley face what is
that maybe in the Japanese version they
draw an actual kanji maybe that's why I
like friendship you can't really do that
so they just drew it it's mine I really
want to know if that's the case all
right okay there it's still it still is
more dramatic um than Japanese what I
just really so they take him to the
hospital
we each begin with 2000 Life Points
first player to hit zero losses so how
are they gonna make a card game
interesting for an anime well of course
Virtua epic arena is so epic for
whatever reason Yugi has this thing
around his neck but it looks like the
most uncomfortable thing you could
possibly carry around your neck but he's
been carrying it around his neck because
for whatever reason and it makes him
transform you know in other animation
like Sailor Moon that there's like this
cool transformation scene every time she
transformed right with Yugi oh it's the
same thing except it just he just
screams Yugi oh and that's it
[Music]
and his balls dropped because his voice
gets 10 times deeper
[Music]
[Applause]
what that now Kaiba prepare yourself
because it's time to do just instant
puberty right there that's how it
happens so let's begin
i attack Sumi giant all right so they
play epically there's no point in me
really doing this your fierce Knight is
destroyed but Kaiba doesn't just summon
one blue ice white dragon with my friend
feat Yugi but three blue-eyes white
dragon
for some reason grandpa in the hospital
as well can follow what's going on look
at it don't give up don't give up you
have to win why grandpa's counting on me
swords of revealing light it stops all
monsters on the field for three turns
how desperate then he also talks to his
granddad for someone claiming to have
faith you're giving up too easily Yugi
listen sometimes the cards are like a
puzzle you have to put all the different
pieces in their proper place shut up
you're dying grandpa
[Music]
I like the animation as well of the
attacks what is that
your judge man falls three blue-eyes
White Dragons my god it's almost like if
you would have had forth if he just
didn't destroy yet that would have been
so cool but anyway he's about to
assemble okay I understand this is very
complex but he's about to assemble the
unstoppable Exodia you need five cards
on the board and if you get all of them
you win the game it's never been done
before but Yugi doesn't believe in
himself he doesn't he doubts the heart
of the cards is of Exodia but the odds
are against me the odds are against him
I don't think I can do this it senses my
doubt lose focus newbie don't lose faith
concentrate my deck senses my doubt
who wrote this it's so good huh our
friendship simple yes
and [ __ ] you down right here weak let's
uh gift you've got to believe in
yourself the same card will show up
regardless does he understand that I
guess I don't believe in the heart of
the cards
dad damn it here it is Paradis here's
the best line of the whole entire anime
draw your last pathetic card so I can
end this Yugi my grandpa's deck has no
pathetic cards Kaiba my grandpa's deck
doesn't have any pathetic cards Kaiba so
good that's writing that's what it does
contain I've assembled all 5 special
cards Oh [ __ ] me I'd at least put
them so he makes the shape like that can
you at least put them like that I mean
that's pretty badass
not gonna lie that's pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
exodia chases quite possible the liquor
shop that kind able to call him there it
is
Saudi ready for the main operate
[Music]
we did it you play only for power Kaiba
and that is why you lost but if you put
your heart in the game there is nothing
you can't do but but how but believing
in the heart of the game is such a weak
mindset but the phrase just to kill me
if you true oh yeah here it gets even
more confusing here what is going on
what is happening what did he just do to
it it just it just doesn't it just says
it just does it bear maybe now you will
begin to see he just shut up granny I
guess sir Seto Kaiba or uncontested
champion he's been defeated my god so
the new enemy is introduced Pegasus
who's his character trait is that he's
drinking wine and I swear to God
for because I watched the whole season
for like ten episodes all he does is
drink wine he must be absolutely clean
hammered
so yeah that's episode 1 of Yukio I
think it's great I know I'm over 30 I'm
not I'm not supposed to enjoy these
things but it's so bad that it's good
you have to understand that distinction
I'm not gonna spoil what happens but
basically Yugi's grandpa gets stuck in
the Shadow Realm
so you he has to duel Pegasus and Joey
Joey joins a log what I'll show the
picture to Joey the reason why Joey has
to win it's because his sister serenity
which he hasn't seen in years might go
blind if he doesn't win that's believing
Joey draws a terrible card oh yeah it's
totally cover together so yeah Yugi Oh
Susan one highly recommended it's a
great anime I apologize for this video
but smash like if you enjoyed regardless
and I'll see you guys tomorrow 68
percent of your subscribe come on
subscribe today bye bye hegel hegel